In listening to low carb keto diets to reduce sugar, it seems that is only half the protocol.
You have to cut the glutamine and other energy sources for cancer cells.
These usually are drugs that are prescribed.
So without a doctor prescribing a drug, if you can find one, what else works to lower glutamine
levels?
So really with glutamine, so if you're trying to, there are some drugs on the market to lower
glutamine, but they're hard to get a hold of now.
I forgot the name of that one.
What was it?
GAD?
I forgot the name of it because I obviously can't prescribe it.
But it was hard to find somebody to use it because you're using it basically on label.
So I don't even know.
I've had several people say that they can't get it, the doctor was trying to prescribe
it.
They can't get any place, they can't buy any place to get it.
So, but so it has been shown to drastically reduce glutamine and some patients that can be
helpful, especially in patients with acercytoma, acercytoma, which is type of brain cancer, can
be fed directly by glutamine.
Remember, your body will make glutamine, it will break down glutamine from glutamates as
well.
Remember, glutamine is a precursor to glutamate, it converts to glutamate, which is a neurotransmitter
in your brain, you need glutamate.
So it's not a matter of not having any glutamine.
So the big thing is you're just watching your glutamine in your diet.
It's a problem is if you're eating meat, you're eating glutamine, there's glutamine in
all meat products, and there's negatives to not eating any animal protein.
So it's really tough.
You've got to find out what's going to work for you.
Many times it's that rotational diet where you're going to go on a diet that is eating meat,
animal products, glutamine for a period of time and you're going to rotate it off and you're
going to be eating very little of it.
So yeah, if you're not going to, it's hard to reduce glutamine down to zero or a year or
zero.
It's very difficult to do.